do you mind taking people through a
timeline of your illness as well as
the course of your recovery nope i don't
mind
i'm getting used to it it's been two
years so i'm getting used to it
um i had no indication that i was ill
i'd gone on a walking tour with my
sister to croatia
we walked for 10 days and it was
wonderful uh i flew home and two weeks
later i got a
fever a fever and a
kind of a gastrointestinal flu of some
sort
and the fever went away but the
digestive
gastrointestinal trouble stayed and so i
eventually went to the doctor and he
told me maybe i had a parasite
i thought oh yeah that's i should have
thought of that
so he gave me a a test and no i didn't
have a parasite oh
okay so then he thought well then let's
do a an ultrasound of your abdomen
uh have you do a colonoscopy you know
all this stuff we'll just look
and i had an ultrasound and i could see
the screen and i saw a shadow on my
kidney
and so eventually
i had a bacterial problem that i
fixed before i had surgery but
they told me i had a renal cell
carcinoma which is a
very common cancer
and people often have it and it doesn't
kill you because it grows
one millimeter a year yeah really really
really slow
and so then he they said don't worry
about it you can i was traveling with my
husband
on a book tour so he they said whenever
you have time you can come in the
hospital and have that surgery
um i flew back during our book tour and
had a biopsy
and i flew back for blood i i had to fly
back a couple of times
in preparation for surgery and then
march
of 2019 i went into the hospital
and i had a partial nephrectomy
of my left kidney and i left the
hospital and for six weeks
my family members gathered around me and
i got better and by six weeks i was
walking to the waterfront and back to
the annex i was healthy and
i went to my post-op appointment with my
husband and
the doctor was nervous
and loathed to talk to us
and when he talked to us he told me that
i had a year to live that they were
wrong
and that i had something called a
bellini tumor
which is very rare in fact so rare that
no
that they have no data on how to treat
it because people die too quickly
and by then it was in one of my lymph
nodes
a lymph node adjacent to my kidney and
they said we have to
you have to have surgery as soon as
possible
and this was around march 2019 this was
april
end of april so then june
or may 9th i had another surgery
but before i went into surgery the night
before i went into surgery
um i meditated
my husband and i were really nervous
super nervous it's no wonder because
surgery was their only treatment they
said radiation and chemo
they had no idea that there was no good
result except for if they got it in time
so my only chance was this surgery
and so i had done a
very interesting meditation when i was
studying to be a massage therapist
years ago when i was in my 20s where
i had a cyst on one of my ovaries
and they thought it was cancer it wasn't
but
i was working with this cool artist
massage therapist guy and he said
that he was going to take me on a
journey
and i could go see what i could find out
about this
so we did a meditation where i
breathed in white light
i breathed in white light and it turned
it ended up to be like a string of light
that wrapped around
my ovary that was spinning around it was
light it was spinning around the ovary
and i was asking what was wrong and if
and if part of me was afraid if
you know if there was trouble there that
it was okay it could come talk to me
and so i was really trying to
communicate and
about two hours after this uh i had a
pain
out the side of my rib cage quite a
uh real noticeable pain out the side of
my rib cage and then
we stopped and i went in for my surgery
and
what they told me was the size of a
softball
was the side of size of like a ping-pong
ball
so whatever it was and it what it was
was a dermoid cyst
which has hair and skin and teeth in it
so teeth teeth
and skin and hair it's kind of like
maybe a
a twin or that was that was never formed
and it grew when i got pregnant so it
seemed like
the hormone change in my body when i was
pregnant
made it grow but i think it it was there
already
so it was something that was waiting to
to develop but i don't it's uh they're
they're quite rare
anyway i had that out i was fine
but it was an interesting experience
because i really felt like i had
touched something inside myself that was
troublesome and i had calmed it down
some in this meditation it seemed that
way so the night before my surgery i
thought let's do that again
so i got jordan to sit at my feet and
move his hands like this up the insides
of my feet
which in reflexology is your
spine your br your birth canal and so it
was very it was touching it
yeah very rhythmically up one set up my
feet and then down my feet
and i said this is going to be about a
two hour get comfortable because this is
about a two hour
meditation and so then i
settled in to bring in the white light
and i decided what i would do because
i'd had a lot of letters come from
all the people that we'd met when we
traveled all over the world
and i had a lot of a lot of prayers and
a lot of
letters come to me when i was first
diagnosed with
cancer and so i lined up all those
people in my mind on a beach
i lined them up on a beach and i had
them pray and i
breathed in all their prayers i breathed
in all the prayers and i took them down
to my kidney
yeah and i first i thought with a white
light and then i thought well this is
cancer let's use a gold light
because this has got to be powerful so i
breathed in gold light
and did you exhale any black muck or
were you just breathing in
i didn't i didn't breathe out any black
muck but after
two hours of
of having a conversation with this
little blackness that i found in my
kidney it seemed like a part of me was
looking the other way and it turned away
from me it looked
it was my like my cells had turned away
and i thought
they had turned away and decided to work
against me rather than with me that's
how it felt to me
and i realized somewhere in the
meditation that cancer is much too much
for one person
that it's something that i had to give
back to the universe and then
a black kind of soot
came out spun out of me and and went up
to into the universe
where it could be better dealt with
because it was too much for me
and then we went to bed and got up in
the morning and we were calm
we were calm we went to the hospital and
i told the surgeon what had happened the
night before in my meditation
he said he took that intention into the
surgery
and the surgery went really well
everything they took out nothing was
adhered to anything else
they didn't have to do any extra cutting
they just pulled out
the rest of the kidney and all the lymph
from my left side and so
i was left with my
remaining kidney and all the lymph on
the right side